[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation you read
the title of this video correctly I have
not seen Willie Wonka in the Chocolate
Factory mentioned that in our Wonka
trailer reaction I did with John and Koy
you see every single month I put
together a giant list of movies I send
it out to all the hosts and I find out
who has not seen what so I can do the
proper pairings and blah blah blah blah
blah and I am the only one on the
channel who has not seen this classic so
you're getting a Greg solo today with
that in mind ladies and Gentlemen please
go ahead leave a like on this video also
subscribe and click the notification
Bell to get notified when we got
something that pops up in your
notification fee that pequs your
interest thank you to prepper for
helping us edit down these highlights
also massive thank you to all who have
joined our patreon for the month of
December just this entire year it's been
our most successful year thus far over
there you can get the full length Gratch
and watchong it's where you sync up with
your own copy of Willy Wonka on the
Chocolate Factory but John and I also
cover several things over there
exclusively with highlights and watch
alongs including the Timothy shalom's
Wonka movie finally coming out fig now
is the perfect time to finally cover
this cuz of algorithm
stuff I'm already in the mood for
chocolate
now I know this tune I've heard this
tune I think I like kind of know the
Oompa Loompa song as
well God I better chocolatey mood
already comment below what is your
favorite chocolate I love me some
Reese's Pieces Reese's Peanut Butter Cup
let me be clear Reese's Peanut Butter
[Applause]
Cup I appreciate the production design
and making sure every kid was wearing
just vibrant colors they look so happy
to be
children listen WKA has got a new one
today a new one scum bar scrum bium bar
scrum TR lescent how does he do it boy
do you ask a fish how it swims no or a
bird how it flies no you do not they do
it because they were born to do it just
like Willie Wonker was born to be a
Candyman who can oh we're in a song
already
spr inate
andac a candy man a the candy
man
cand I don't think I've heard this
song a
rain like how back then they would trust
this man with a bunch of children Willy
Wonka makes everything he FES satisfying
and delicious what a way to build a
Willy Wonka right
away that's some great editing right
there very well composed so
[Music]
far
taste
fickle grubbers what are the names of
these
[Music]
candies that's Charlie why wasn't he
bonding with the rest of the
children it's payday Mr JC you're right
where's my money there you are
thanks I know we're only a couple
minutes in but this movie is already
conveying such a sense of optimism I
want to
say feels a lot more for boing than I
was expecting it
to that's a really cool shot did they
build some [__] that looks great up the
Airy Mountain down the rushing Glen dare
not go a hunting for fear of little men
fear of little men you see it's rude
nobody ever goes in nobody ever comes
[Music]
out F of is night blades jangling around
Charlie's late he works too hard for a
little boy he should have some time to
play not you train him now wow what an
uncomfortable sleeping situation what
the hell is going on here is this your
supper Grandpa I'm fed up with cabbage
water it's not enough
Charlie wee Charlie you watch that foul
language how about this Charlie where'd
you get that it's my first payday good
for you Charlie we'll have a real
banquet a he used his first payday to
give them bread from now on I'm going to
pay for your tobacco why won't my nephew
do that for me not since the tragic day
that Willy Wonka locked it why do you
lock it because all the other chocolate
makers in the world were sending in
spies to steal Mr Wonka's secret recipes
especially slugworth oh that slugworth
he was the worst Mr woner shouted I
shall be ruined Clos the factory and
that's just what he did with the
Candyman song it makes him seem like oh
so pleasant and then this side of him
makes him sound scary three years later
the most amazing thing happened the
factory started working again and more
delicious candies were coming out than
ever before you found Hope but the gate
stayed locked someone must be helping Mr
Wonka work the factory thousands must be
helping him but who children from
Cambodia Charlie Bucket yes Mr Turk I
shall need an assistant come and give me
a hand foreshadowing what do you think
it makes I don't know sir course you
don't know you don't know because only I
know if you knew and I didn't know then
you'd be teaching me instead of me
teaching
you what a sassy little teacher and I'll
take my own special mixture are you
ready good lad
po this is very big walls get El going
on out there is this going to come back
in later in the movie what's happening
Willy Walkers opening his Factory he's
going to let people in ooh giving
truckloads of chocolate away class
dismissed no no it's only for five
people class UND
dismissed five golden tickets and the
people who find them will win the big
prize where's he hidden the tickets
inside five Walker bars you got to buy
Wonka bar to find
them this does some surprisingly
impressive World building even as an
audience m going yeah i' be trying to
like rack up as many Wonka Bars as
possible right now and to the five
people who find them will come the most
fabulous prize one could wish for a
lifetime supply of chocolate o they're
all
crazy a genius he'll sell a million bars
greatest form of capitalism Wonka Bars
are beginning to disappear from candy
store shelves at a rate to Boggle the
Mind truly it is incredible the way that
wonam Mania has descended upon the globe
it's it's cut this like weird dual layer
of of Wonder and semi thre threatening
at the same time dreams doctor and I
still can't stop myself from believing
them to believe in one's dreams is a
manifestation of insanity and the sooner
you accept this the sooner you'll get
well well color me insane doctor but I
dreamed the Archangel appeared and
whispered into my ear and told me where
to find a golden Wonka ticket and what
exactly did he say he wants to know I'm
a you said just shut up PO and tell me
where the ticket is
the first golden ticket was found in the
small town of delheim Germany damn
Germans today right here in dlim the
unexpected discovery of the first Wonka
golden ticket man there's some great
Rhythm to this son of our most prominent
Park butcher austo Glo the fame of
Western Germany an example for the whole
world yes congratulations you're hard
worker feel sorry for Wonka it's going
to cost an unfortunate fetch Mr would
you mind say
[Laughter]
gold ticket eating is his hob you know
we he wouldn't do it unless the hell is
going on here some scary German
scientist happy birthday here you are
Charlie terrific we each knitted a bit
Grandma Georgina Grandma Josephine and
me and here's a little gift from Grandpa
George and me so they can never get out
of that bed must smell so bad in there
open it Charlie let's see that golden
ticket it's not fair to raise his hopes
never mind go on open it Charlie I want
to see that gold stop it I'm going to
buy so many lottery tickets after I'm
done
filming I got it where where let's see
old you didn't I you thought I really
had it what was the point of that what
was your intention young man I want you
to be the first to find a golden ticket
Daddy I know Angel we're doing the best
we can oh my goodness all right where is
it why haven't they found it barus
someone comment below the fact of how
much money they spent on Chocolat and
rappers they're jealous of me sweetheart
I can't push them no harder 19,000 bars
an hour they're shelling 760,000 have'
done so far oh my God you're going to be
very unpopular around here Henry if you
don't deliver soon I hate to see her
unhappy I won't talk you ever again
you're a rotten mean
[Music]
[Laughter]
father
what a little BR I got it I got
it I would have just kept it for
myself I found the golden
ticket wait he was the one with the the
German boy just had a total Ryan George
with there he was the one with the
German
boy whichever of the five continents we
are on the great search for Wonka Bars
continues look at that person in the
background watching we're beginning to
see signs of anxiety every hour on the
hour new shipments are being sent to
different points around the globe this
mve is like a scorsi movie Miss Violet
borgard finder of Wonka's golden ticket
number three parents Mr borgard a
prominent local politician friend Sam
borgard here Square Deal s to you
with here it is golden ticket number
three and it's all M tell us how it
happened Violet this poor Charlie kid
cuz I laid off the gum and switch to
candy bars instead now of course I'm
right back on gum chew it all day except
at meal times when I stick it behind my
ear call it mother wish a rotten
children now this piece of gum here is
one that I've been chewing on for 3
months solid and that's a world record
is what is the purpose of this
child he's the guy with a German boy how
does he get to all these children just
sneaks up on them right in their ear I
wanted to tell you something they found
a third ticket today did they no Mrs
bugget just doesn't even believe that
it's possible POS there only two tickets
left you know pretty soon just one I
wonder who the lucky ones will be well
in case you're wondering if it'll be me
it won't be just in case you're
wondering you can count me out no don't
give me that attitude Charlie there are
100 billion people in this world and
only five of them will find golden
tickets and after this contest is over
you'll be no different from the billions
of others who didn't find one wow you
are not a very empowering mom One day
things will change when when will they
change for things to change you have to
change it's better to be prepared for an
opportunity and not have one happen than
to have an opportunity and not be
[Music]
prepared oh okay she's just protecting
himile
these poor people I don't mean just
financially
[Music]
poor oh what a great
shot oh whoa they pulled out from the
shadow like that this kid has a lot
going on behind his eyes glad
you're
you I keep saying kid but he's
definitely older than me now if he's
still around I don't know lucky winner
number four now the name soon to be
heard around the universe is Mr Mike TV
hey Mike do you think we might shut that
thing off no are you
crazy he doesn't even give a [__] about
this new why are all these children so
snotty you like the killings huh what do
you think life's all about Mike would
you tell us wait till I get a real one
cold 45 oh jeez pop won't let me have
one yet will you pop not till you're 12
son not till you're
12 who is this man they keep letting
into people's children they just let let
them around children they got to stop
it Grandpa that money was for tobacco I
told you Charlie I've given it up a
these two which end shall I open first
that end just a tiny
bit like
this this
kid who is now a senior citizen is so
adorable here
goes I bet those golden tickets make the
chocolate taste
[Music]
terrible I love him so much they
kidnapped my husband 12 hours ago I'll
give them anything anything they want
the hell is this
plotline go ahead we're
listening what did they ask for they
watch your case of Wonka
bars it's your husband's life or your
case of wab
bars how long will that get me to think
it
[Laughter]
over this is so well
done that was so funny the fifth and
last colon ticket has just been found
right here in Paraguay Alberto moleta
the multi-millionaire owner of caming
casinos for South America damn 1% R
little boy's got to have something in
this world to hope for what's he got to
hope for now who's going to tell him
let's not wake him he'll find out soon
enough a poor kid I mean I know what the
plot of what's going to happen but man
the immediate moment you really feel
[Music]
it
I have no idea what he just picked up is
that some kind of currency I'd like a
bar of chocolate please a slug Sizzler
Wonka scrum didly ous whichever's the
biggest try a Wonka scrum didly ous now
that all the tickets have been found I
don't have to hide them
anymore he's such a sweet kid I just
feel so bad for him you'll get a stomach
ache if you swallow it like that bye bye
now like that just like the sadness and
hopefulness I just feel it he's a good
act
this old man now I think I'll buy just
one more why not try a regular wabal
this time that Gambler from Paraguay
made up a phony ticket that means
there's one golden ticket still floating
around
somewhere seriously who is this kid I
have no idea who he
[Music]
is man the direction on this the
emphasis on the chocolate bar
hey you've got it you've got the last
golden ticket the kids found the last
ticket and then that guy with the scar
shows up it's a whisper something into
his ear come on hold on to the ticket
run for it Charlie run straight home and
don't stop till you get there
aw yo this is some touching ass [__]
right now
and I knew this was going to happen
too that's when you know something's
freaking
effective who are
you may I introduce myself please ask
slugworth president of slugworth
chocolates Incorporated uh he's a
spy Mr Wonka is at this moment working
on a fantastic invention uh-huh the
Everlasting Gobstopper e that sounds
gross so all I want you to do is to get
hold of just one Everlasting gobs and
bring it to me so that I can find the
secret formula Christopher Lloyd from
who frame Roger Rabbit your reward will
be 10,000 of these think it over with
you a new house for your family he's got
morals Charlie would never I Don't Know
Jack about that plot it's prime example
of solid execution even if if you you
know that like yeah I know he supposed
to get the ticket and go to the factory
but damn does it work the last one was a
fake it on the papers I found some money
in the street and I bought a Wonka bar a
ticket was in
it present this ticket at the factory
gates at 10:00 in the morning of the
first day of October you may bring with
you one member of your own family but no
one else bring one of the grandpa who do
wasn't talking say I can take somebody
with me I wish you could
go this movie is going to break me I can
feel it oh
man Charlie I did not expect it to be so
touching that's good Charlie he's going
to float like the
Exorcist damn he's doing it
are you okay I'm fine
Charlie these other two not
talk look at me he's
standing kick Charlie in the head I
never thought my life could be oh they
know when to CU these musical numbers
man so well so well
calculated suddenly I begin
see not going to lie guys St this movie
might be a bit of a chore but I am
loving it so
much I never had a chance to
shineing oh he's going around and
[Music]
around what a catchy ass song I never
thought i' see the day when I would face
the world
as
just like boisterous
Wonder but it can be done we haven't
even got a willly Wonka
yet I never dreed that I would climb
over the moon in nextasy but
nevertheless it's there that I'm shortly
about to be a great
song The
Gold I I don't have I heard this song
before I must have at some point in my
life but it can
be never dreed that oh wow he's really
[Music]
moving okay now it's going to the point
where you're mocking everyone else on
the
bed I really had this like preconceived
belief that I would be sitting here
going all right let's just wait till
willly Wonka shows up and then maybe
it'll be become really fun but we're
like 40 minutes in and I'm still like
I'm really enjoying that hell out of it
hiel sweetie I've still got it now is
this God your job must hurt so bad look
at this chocolate man has a scar I want
to go in first before anybody else
anything you say sweetheart save some
for
later yo kid you need to get some blood
work done
[Music]
wow the build maybe this isn't a good
idea that I'm watching this before the
Timothy shallow one just going to
compare it the whole
[Applause]
time oh he's got a
limp I thought it was just like a
stylistic choice like a Monopoly man or
something do Monopoly man eat a cane for
walking purposes well clearly all the
chocolate has affected the circulation
in his feet due to the diabetes he
developed great beat what oh hey he
didn't need the Kate after all is a
trickster I'm so glad you could come
this is going to be such an exciting day
I hope you enjoy it I think you will
[Music]
he got so much there a natural mystery
about him AUST Aus my dear boy how good
to see you and in such fine
shape yeah I'm Mike TV well you're dead
wonderful to meet you Mike and Miss
Stevie how do you do what an adorable
little boy you have thank you just over
there that's speed on him I'm so happy
for you and who's this gentleman my
grandfather Grandpa Joe delighted to
meet you sir overjoyed and raptured and
transed are we ready yes solid vacular
hats coats gashes over here but hurry
please we have so much time and so
little to see wait a minute strike that
reverse it thank
[Laughter]
you little surprises around every corner
but nothing dangerous and as soon as
you're outer vestments are in hand we'll
begin oh that's fun where coming from
floods fire Frost of fery what I got
keep up with this sign anything for this
tour I can't see what it says in the
bar I don't sign anything without my
lawyer my Brer don't sign anything
either then she don't go in I'm Sorry
rules of the house I want to go in don't
you dare stop me just s it you're always
making things
difficult nicely handled Bara she's a
girl who knows where she's going I like
how he's like auring but you don't know
if you could trust
him there is no other door there's no
way out God most of you are very
unlikable ah here we are don't be a darn
fool Wonka that's the way we came in it
is he is a
magician what is this W some kind of fun
house why having fun i' had how
clever
hey the room is smaller no it's not he's
getting bigger where's the chocolate I
doubt if there is any what is the point
of building a factory like this and some
of my realities become dreams and almost
everything you'll see is eatable
edible me I'm starving now don't get
over excited don't lose your head
Augustus we wouldn't want anyone to lose
that yet he's such a great listener like
the way he responds to everyone one hold
your breath make a wish count to
three
come and you'll I know this
song it's the H
song into your
[Music]
[Laughter]
imagination what a way to play
multifaceted if you want to view
Paradise simply look around and VI are
the stairs
edible hurry up Violet this way Grandpa
you enjoy that chocolate eat everything
can you eat the ground no in my luck I
would eat the thing that is not actually
edible oh oh my God what is this place
[Music]
That Tune there's something that feels
like questionably malevolent about
[Music]
it you be
free who are you Wonka it's Industrial
Waste that you've ruined your Watershed
Wonka it's polluted is chocolate that's
chocolate that's chocolate two very
different responses
10,000 Gall an hour and look at my
waterfall that's the most important
thing it's mixing my chocolate it's
actually churning my chocolate uh-huh
Grandpa look over there across the river
they're little men the the OA loomas are
OA loomas problematic now must be
creaming and sugaring time well they
can't be real people well of course
they're real people can't be real people
from LPA land LPA land there's no such
place Mr Wonka I am a teacher geography
oh well then you know all about it and
what a terrible country it is and the
poor little Oompa loas were so small and
helpless they would get gobbled up right
and left he's so sincere in his delivery
man he's getting such a great listener
hey Daddy I want an ump lumper I'll get
you one before the day's out I want an
LP lumper now oh my God look at Augustus
don't worry he can't drink it all don't
do that you're contaminating my entire
River please I beg you
Augustine just stand there do something
help Police
Murder it looks like he's droning dive
in save him oh it's too
late so
dismissive there's his cat going up the
pipe call a plumber stuck in the pipe
there isn't he Wonker he's blocking all
the chocolate what happens now or the
pressure will get him out it's all part
of the
plan he's done he'll be made into
marshmallows in 5 seconds impossible my
dear lady that's absurd because that
pipe doesn't go to the marshmallow room
it goes to the fudge
room take Mrs gloop straight to the
fudge room but look sharp or her little
boy liel to get poured into the boiler
goodbye Mrs gloop one
down I've got a puzzle for these are the
rest of the
lyrics oh my
[Music]
God oh my God it's a music
video oh
all I know is OA looma D Doo so he
rescued the Oompa Loompas but turned
them into his own workers but are they
happier what's the deal with the oompas
All Aboard everybody uh ladies first and
that means Vera if she's a lady I'm a
vermicious knit vermicious kit I love
that phrasing percious
kit
what a fun little ride what a great
set hi where are we going I don't know
but I don't like look that tunnel up
there hey Wonka I went off I
[Music]
don't terminal velocity have we in know
what what the hell is going on hang on
darling close your eyes and hang
on oh this is this is creepy as hell
what the hell is going on tell that
little guy to turn us around walk out
now I am going to be
sick couldn't is this just revealing
internally what they're experiencing
this is like a drug trip is a hurricane
of blowing not a speck of light is
showing so the danger must be growing
damn some good slam poetry and there's
certainly not
showing any signs that they are slowing
I believe this guy could kill them stop
D this should go far enough quite right
sir stop
theat we're
there they're inventing room no messing
about no touching no tasting no telling
and whoever doesn't obey the rules gets
in
trouble I just get the the impression
this movie was a production nightmare
but damn how cool would it be to walk on
this set this is the most secret machine
in my entire Factory this is the one
that's really going to sizzle old
slugworth what's it do uh-oh would you
like to see
yeah feel like I've seen that still
before but what's it do can't you see it
makes Everlasting Gob Stoppers that's
the thing you can suck them and suck
them and suck them and they'll never get
any smaller how do you make
I'm a trifle deaf in this ear speak a
little louder next time the sarcasm
water is so well done and never show
them to another living Soul As Long as
You All Shall Live agreed agreed agreed
fingers cross and one for you and one
for you what about Charlie and one for
Charlie what happens if you take it out
of your mouth how do you preserve it
she's my revolutionary non-pollution
mechanical
Wonder whoa they really build this stuff
this little piece of gum is a three
course dinner I wouldn't do that I
really wouldn't so long as it's
gum damn his delivery is perfect it's
tomato soup it's hot and creamy I can
actually feel it running down my throat
delicious here it comes blueberry pie
and cream it's the most marvelous
blueberry pie I've ever tasted holy too
What's happen into your face she's
changing colors oh she's a violet
turning Violet Violet thingy yeah but
your face is turning blue oh no blue
you're turning Violet Violet it is that
one yeah yeah yeah what's happening
you're blowing up like a balloon like a
blueberry you really done it this time
having you Wonka hey he said not to eat
it would you roll the young lady down to
the juicing room at once please what for
for
squeezing got another puzzle for you
they don't look
confident
sure why can't you come on camera now
you're just having fun with her I got a
blueberry for a daughter where is fancy
bread in the heart or in the head shall
We Roll on that is a good question I
love these like bars that he drops no
pun intended Wonka bars he keeps
dropping what's it making Mr Wonka fizzy
lifting drinks they fill you with gas
and the gas is so terrifically lifting
that it lifts you right off the ground
like a balloon wa but I dareen sell it
yet it's still too powerful come on let
us try some please no absolutely not
there'd be children floating around all
over the place let's take a drink
Charlie nobody's watching yeah a small
one won't hurt us whoops no guys no
guys not bad I can't understand
why we're in big trouble it's a very
interesting structure because it's so
much about Charlie in the beginning that
didn't Charlie kind of takes a back seat
once we get
here oh oh this is great oh that's cool
rather than them having a torturous
experience or having a joyous one watch
this
Grandpa Wonderful Child wow what kind of
set is this I'm going to
hi P I can't get down pull him down
we're in trouble Charlie I can't stop
it's pulling me in it would still be fun
to try this drink out though please turn
off the fan
oh they got to burp your way down burp
burp if you don't get down the ribbon I
can't boy burp again
B up boy come on that's kind of gross
they can't be doing what they're doing
but they are they have to I haven't met
the Oompa Loompa yet who could do it
these are the geese that lay the golden
egg just acknowledges it they have to he
just like turns right to them as if they
haven't left the room the geese are very
temperamental that's why we have the
eggdicator the eggdicator can tell the
difference between a good egg and a bad
egg I love all the props they built if
it's a good egg it's shined up and
shipped out all over the world have they
create some type of like attraction
where you can go visit these things hey
Daddy I want a Golden Goose Daddy I'll
get you Golden Goose as soon as we get
home no I want one of those one one of
those I want one now how much do you
want for the Golden Goose they're not
for sale name me promise she can't have
one sure we didn't cut to WKA on that by
the way I want to Feast you EG before
you came to the factory I want a bean
feast what a little bruts and fruit
NOS you're going to have all those
things when you get home no now I wonder
what she was really like on set she
would what was she she
[Music]
Pleasant you're distracting the Oompa
Loompas from doing their
job am especially perturbs
me
[Music]
oh my God what a devil
woman I hope one of the eggs falls on
her head oh God she was a bad
egg where' she gone to the furnace it's
so matter of fact hold on Bara
sweetheart daddy's
coming that a
horrible
there's a sadness in his performance
too
blame I love how they get these like
music video subtitle
[Music]
videos they are instilling life lessons
places please the dance is about to
begin everybody set is this going to go
fast Grandpa it's sure Charlie has got
more gas in it than a politician I love
that one stronger than
[Music]
[Applause]
lion I'm sending you the cleaning Mr
W FR clean
wow that is awesome what was that we
just went
through is that Japanese no that's Wonka
spelled
backwards there's dangerous stuff inside
Wonka Vision television uh it's w Vision
uh it's w ofion you photograph something
then the photograph is split up into
millions of tiny pieces and they go
whizzing through the air down to your TV
set where they're all put together again
in the right order you should open your
m a little wider when you speak
I shall now send this chocolate bar from
one end of the room to the other
action but does it cause your the the
chocolate to be radiated heads in a
million pieces whoa now watch the screen
there it is it's real taste it it's
delicious it's just gotten smaller
that's all it's perfect it's
unbelievable it's a miracle it's a TV
dinner it's Wonka Vision it's Wonka
Vision can you send other things what
about people get in there kid but it
might have some messy results look at me
I'm going to be the first person in the
world to be sent by television get away
from that thing stop don't come back I
love how like disconcert he actually
is where are you he's up there in a
million
pieces so not face he's going to be tiny
though mik why is he taking so long
million pieces take a long time to put
together oh where are they look at me
everybody I'm the first person in the
world to be sent by television you're
not grasping the consequences of are you
little boy what you taking me I don't
want to go in there be quiet how will he
grow well fortunately small boys are
extremely springy and elastic so I think
we'll put him in my special tattoo
pulling machine just swinging him around
her you'll find the boy in his mother's
purse but be extremely
careful
parting is such sweet sorrow it's kind
of a physically demanding movie on the
actors isn't
it I'm
[Music]
listening I don't
know I
amen too much
[Music]
work
and that was the end of them Mr Wonka
what's going to happen to the other kids
I promise you they'll be quite all right
when they leave here they'll be
completely restored to their normal
terrible old
selves and what do we do now Mr Wonka
straight up the stairs you'll find the
way I'm terribly busy whole day wasted
goodbye to you both whole day wasted
what happened did we do something wrong
a
everything's in half here I just wanted
to ask about the chocolate when does he
get it he doesn't because he broke the
rules under section 37b of the contract
signed by him I shall forfeit all rights
hearing and hearing contained etc
etc that's kind of a con you stole fizzy
lifting drinks you bumped into the
ceiling which now has to be washed so
you get nothing wow he's kind of cruel
how can you do a thing like this build
up a little boy's hopes and then smash
all his dreams to Pieces you're an
inhuman monster I said good day oh
that's so sad Mr
Wonka he won't give it over
Charli youve won forgive me for putting
you through this please forgive me come
in Mr Wilkinson Charlie meet Mr
Wilkinson oh my God I had to test you
Charlie and you passed it test I did not
actually see that
coming this is the Great Glass
wonkavator it's an elevator it's a
wonkavator there it goes you mean we're
going up and out but this roof is made
of glass it'll chatter in a thousand
pieces will be cut to Ribbons probably
it's actually kind of
terrifying here it
comes
whoa
with the Pure
Imagination how did you like the
Chocolate Factory Charlie I think it's
the most wonderful place in the whole
world I'm very pleased to hear you say
that because I'm giving it to
you you're giving Charlie the I can't go
on forever and I don't really want to
try so who can I trust to run the
factory when I leave
a that's why I decided a long time ago
that I I had to find a child a very
honest loving child to whom I can tell
all my most precious Candy Making
Secrets good thing you fixed them at
random so the factory is yours Charlie
you can move in immediately what happens
to the rest the whole family I want you
to bring them all really everyone don't
forget what happened to the man who
suddenly got everything he always wanted
what happened he lived happily ever
after what a great move movie this movie
is actually so
good big
surprise oh my
God what happened to Peter ostram ostram
Aloha reject Nation Greg here so many of
you guys know most of my days or a
couple of hours of filming and then most
of the time it's dedicated to like
editing and a bunch of other computer
work often it can be like to like 10 to
12 hours a day and on top of that
comfort food is like my life's biggest
Vice but as many of you also know
working out and getting healthier has
been a massive component for me this
year in particular so in this Whirlwind
I have found myself a perfect Ally for
quick healthy meals America's number one
meal kit a meal kit that I have
subscribed to prior to ever agreeing and
working with them so yes this is a
genuine testimony and that is of course
for hellofresh and hellofresh is in just
about ease about bringing health and
flavor to you your doorstep in this
holiday season forget about the stress
of planning meals for your healthc
conscious friends friends like me who
will breede down the back of your neck
being like I can't eat that that's
unhealthy so with hell fresh I'm looking
forward to hosting holiday dinners that
are not only delicious but also cater to
Healthy Lifestyles best part the variety
it is incredible I'm pescatarian so they
have these delicious meals just like
Dijon onion crunch salmon over lemon
broccoli spaghetti and for my more
plant-based days to vegan Maple carrot
power bowls they aren't just meals
they're culinary Adventures I learned
the word word culinary during a long day
the last thing I want to do is spend a
while cooking and that's where helloof
Fresh's 15minute meals are a lifesaver
they're quick nutritious and Oho tasty
perfect for my non-stop lifestyle so why
not join me in making this holiday
season both health conscious and
delicious with hellofresh with over 45
recipes and seasonal add-ons to choose
from every week there's always something
new to try and here's something to cheer
about go to hellofresh.com reject free
and use code reject free for free
breakfast for life is that accurate
that's sounds way too good to be true
there's no way that can be true go to
hellofresh.com reex free and use code
reject free for free breakfast for Life
One breakfast item per box as long as
your subscription is active tag your
hellofresh creations with hashtag
hellofresh pic and at hellofresh and
let's cook up some fun and healthiness
reject Nation remember it's America's
number one meal kit Okie doie ladies and
gentlemen uh boys and girls ah I quite
loved this movie prior to starting it I
was a bit apprehensive you see when I
was like really really young don't ask
me what scene I just remember having a
thought when I was a kid going oh wait
no okay let me start this again all
righty guys well if you're listening to
this on Apple or Spotify please rate
that video we got a real rejects podcast
going for those watching us here on
YouTube I'm trying to I'm trying to
conduct this for two different audiences
one who just hear and one who can see
any who uh just watched wiie Wonka in
the Chocolate Factory first time ever
and a little bit of background here
probably should have given this on the
said on the patreon one but I should
give it on the YouTube one so I did I
did see the Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory movie the one that Tim Burton
did when it first came out in the
theaters I barely remember it I mean
that with the utmost sincerity barely
remember what happens in that film uh I
remembered like basically about that
Charlie eventually gets to the chra
Factory and then Johnny de's a little
creepy um but I honestly kind of part of
my brain was was racking St going he he
gets does he get the chocolate fact I
was kept like asking myself that was
like I think he gets the chocolate B but
I don't remember if he does and yeah
it's like I I definitely didn't remember
it well enough to like be making
comparisons or or have an idea of like
oh here's what the structure the movie
is I don't even remember if this
slugworth or whatever the hell this
guy's name is is in the Johnny Depp one
or not like so that was like the the
most Association I have with it and um
when I was a kid I I I saw maybe like 30
seconds of this on TV and I must have
been like really really young and I went
this looks like an old movie I don't
want to watch it and I just never did
but here I am now and I I loved it I
really did love it it it it is such a
fascinating experience because while you
know it while it is from an older era I
do find the way this movie is executed
to feel rather Timeless like I I wasn't
distracted by the period in which it was
captured if anything like it actually
helps amplify the experience and the
magic behind it of making this feel even
more Fantastical by the era itself set
and so I don't know like if I guess my
question that I'm asking is the year in
which the I don't know if this movie
makes it explicitly clear when it takes
place like what year it does because
this is all a fictional world of of this
guy with this amazing Chocolate Factory
and everyone just wants a piece of that
candy uh I I don't know what year it
takes place in in the movie itself but
is it supposed to take place for
whatever year this movie came out in the
70s is it supposed to take place then
does this take place in the 70s what I'm
asking I don't know you guys let me know
below uh but I actually feel like the it
encapsulates it more in a way that does
have it feel a lot more magical due to
that fact uh and I I love the production
design of everything it's everything is
so vibrant it pops uh the entire film
just had this sort of uh Whimsical
Elegance about it it's it's structured
in a in kind of an odd way if there was
one bit of criticism that I might
it's strange because the first like 40
minutes you don't go to wiie Wonka
you're like kind of building him up
right and I really love that part of the
the movie a lot like my heart was so in
it when it came to everyone looking for
the golden tickets and kind of hopping
around the world and seeing who's who
and and how everyone responds to this
and it was really funny it seemed like
that this play on society that I was
really enjoying and and Charlie who is
the guy who plays Charlie my God I gotta
look him up I I just got to look him up
and I'm gonna kill the dead air while
I'm here uh 1971 is when this came out
because yeah I I don't know if this this
kid is still alive uh he's not a kid
anymore that's for sure is he alive
Peter ostram did he only do one
movie is that it what happened to
him what happened to this guy I don't
even see like Modern Day photos of
him okay well he was in something called
remembering Jee Wilder in
2023 so I imagine he's still around and
kicking it a little bit but anyway um I
thought he was excellent uh he he really
captured this sort of like innocence
this this
Purity that felt just so multi-layer
like yeah he's got this like optimism
this hopefulness and um this uh exudes
empathy and all all basically all the
qualities that Willie Wonka lists about
him you know with the the honesty and
the
integrity and and at the same time he's
got this like resilience and
perseverance about his attitude that I
that that I I love so much because
whenever an obstacle was thr his way he
would try to find a way to be optimistic
he never like got too down in the
gutters about anything and I I feel like
just the way he was played was perfect I
really cared about him and it you could
feel kind of that the the way how true
optimism ought to be executed is you got
to have that feeling of H you're you're
constantly up against the wall of
feeling defeated and that's why you have
to have optimism for example like if if
you were to have courage you must have
an element of fear otherwise what's the
point of Courage because courage has to
be the thing that's counteracting
against fear right and and I really
think he he embodied that so well and
like the relationship with his grandpa
that I thought well Grandpa Joe is the
character's name uh again uh you know
even though he is an elderly man he I
thought he had such a a youthful Spirit
about him as well and for him to be sort
of this uh Storyteller and mentor to
Charlie was great like I just really
love the characters and I wasn't
expecting that because they had such a
curiosity and enthusiasm about them that
and so much support and love as well so
all that like lay it on to it with
really catchy Tunes really catchy songs
and and very appealing visuals and the
way the movie is also edited it mov like
the first 40 minutes kind of felt like
it was edited sort of like a Martin
scorsi movie which which was the last
thing I expected to say when going into
Wily Wonka film but it did remind me a
bit of like a scorsi fast-paced editing
style of something that he would have
made in in the 70s but you know was a
lot more PG friendly and less gangster
Catholic driven and so I really I really
loved it cuz there was such a youthful
Spirit about it uh from beginning to end
and then when you get to like Willie
Wonka the movie then
adapts you know what it does it's it's
actually now that I'm thinking about
like with the words I was about to say
it sly made me appreciate it because the
first 40 minutes while you do cut around
other people it's still primarily your
are watching it from Charlie's
perspective and and then when you get to
Wily Wonka now you are the audience
observing like you are one of the golden
ticket winners who are on this journey
with with Willie Wonka and and you're
just trying to figure out who this guy
is because like Gan Wilder nailed it you
know um I I remember like not mind in
the the Charlie and the CH Factory
Johnny Depp one uh but clearly I've
never cared to revisit it I don't didn't
leave an impression on me when I was
younger I definitely didn't hate it I
remember thinking it was creepier um but
I but what what they did here with Gene
Wilder and I you know and just kind of
having a bit of an understanding of how
Gene Wilder operates I imagine he was
very much creatively involved more than
we might expect uh yeah he's very
eccentric very whim musical I think he
does capture that creative Innovative
side of wily Wonka but yet there's that
mystery the the the secrecy behind him
that it is very captivating and same
time he's got the the dark humor and
he's got this sarcasm and yet there's
still a um a depth behind those eyes
like I believe that whole speech at the
end that that was the entire motive even
if even if there was a bit of a ploy
there in order to provoke Charlie into
giving up they slug nugget they I don't
remember what this was called the candy
thing to to test him uh I you still
believe this this um this sadness and
this melan there's a bit of like a
Melancholy and a bit of vulnerability to
him I thought it's actually a really
multi-layered performance even though
it's not one where you're like ah here's
how he starts and here's this character
Arc or something like that that's like
explicitly clear and while a big part of
it is to keep you at a distance and make
him mysterious and a bit like
mischievous and do I really trust this
guy he seems a little bit scary but I
also kind of love
him I believed every I I felt like the
unpredictability and the uh overall
ambiguity of right that's the right
choice of words the the unpredictability
ambiguity of of this character genan
Wilder just embodied it so
well my initial impression and I made a
comment about it while I was doing the
reaction though is that I did kind of
feel like we lost sight while we do
become the audience kind of observing
willly Wonka and you were hopping back
and forth between how Willie Wonka is
observing and stuff and and that is like
the overall game I did find myself like
losing a sense of that connection with
Charlie which was the the thing that the
movie hooked me in when the first 40
minutes is uh we are living vicariously
through Charlie he is the character who
we are latched on to and then through a
lot of the journey throughout the
Chocolate Factory
you're not really in Charlie's
perspective and you don't really cut to
him a lot and I I did miss I did I did
find myself craving that the last thing
I expected to to say was I I just wanted
to spend more time with Charlie while
we're in the Chocolate Factory and I I
do think that is one of the the like
while I while I I have two sides two
feelings about it and it's possible to
have two feelings and I got two feelings
about it one is I love being in the
audience perspective and just watching
Willie Wonka do I keep want to call
Willy Wonka Charlie uh watching Willie
Wonka do his thing and then the other
side is oh but I I'm the character
journey of being in Charlie's shoes and
getting a little bit more nuggets of of
of like maybe Willie Wonka observing
Charlie and seeing how it contrasts
against the choices that the other kids
do I did find myself missing some of
that but by the time you get to the
finale and and I still really enjoyed
the journey throughout the Chocolate
Factory I did I like it's psychedelic
it's weird as hell um but I I loved it I
I did love it and then when you do get
to the the final moments it is it is
extremely touching and it it does feel
cathartic you know and and earned and
like I could see how there are some
things that maybe the story might not
have aged as strong as people might I
don't know I don't really give a [__]
like the one the one thing that come
comes to mind is seems a little bit
moralistic you know he kind of seems
judgmental of people but whatever this
is a [__] movie from the 70s and it's
a family film and they're keeping it
simple they're keeping it simple and and
I really liked it but but even if you do
have that feeling I think there's a lot
of great morality lessons there's a lot
of like good cautionary tale stuff about
um things against the deadly sins you
know the greed gluttony uh laziness and
and uh I I feel like there is uh like
commentary on wealth disparity and and
also the appreciation
of you know just like family and
connection and the the simple the simple
things of life you know but also uh the
encouragement on imagination you know
like the songs really speak a lot of
volumes to that and and and and the
value of of being a of maintaining
integrity and and um I I I also imagine
that there's probably some um I don't
imagine I think it's there in the movie
there there seems to be like commentary
too on on
parenting and and the importance of how
you raise a kid and how a lot of this is
instilled in the value of like because
you got the grandpa like the dad's not
around for Charlie but you got Grandpa
and Charlie and then here you're
watching the relationship between like
either a father and a a child or a
mother and a child and you're watching
how these children developed and how the
parents kind of spoil them and there
seems to be a lot of uh emphasis on
parenting as well and that how important
that is to the development of a child h
i I really loved that aspect of it and
just um overall yeah it's great it's
great film with the enigmatic qualities
of wily Wonka but there's just this
Spirit of innovation throughout and
while there's like some um caution Ary
tale elements to it with wonderful music
and great performances solid Direction
all around and just a lot of heart it
just has a lot of heart I thought this
was a really solid film and I could see
why it stands a test of time and I don't
even I don't have no Nostalgia for this
and I I found myself very much moved and
I'm very surprised by just how much I
ended up loving it I thought I'd be more
here going you know I really appreciated
it and I could see why people like it
let me tell you why I think people
really like it uh I did not actually
expect to walk out of this movie going
wow I really did love it um and and I
loved it before we even got to Wily
Wonka and that to me is a testament to
this movie strength but guys uh how do
you feel about Willie Wonka on the
Chocolate Factory do you like the Johnny
Depp one and are you excited for the
Timothy sham one what is your favorite
moment from here uh if there's something
I did not talk about that you wish
talked about well you can talk about it
in the comments below thank you again
and uh I'll catch you all soon thank you
guys so much for being here rejack
night John pick a name any name oh how
about Maria Hammond Maria Hammond you
know what you're getting for Christmas
this year oo you're going to get you
know I thought of a really dirty joke
and then I thought you you know as as
close as we've
gotten I still am like I feel like I'm
one joke away from completely ruining
all Goodwill we have established with
each other Maria so now I'm not as conf
should I just go for it I think it's a
super light dirty Joe it's like not even
that dirty but I was like you know we're
always like ah you're like the mother at
our patreon you like a son and I was
like that was be kind of weird if I made
a dirty joke well I I mean it depends on
if the joke is about that context I
guess all right okay there's a way to
make both of this work all right Maria
you're going to get a Polaroid of me
naked this year and then you're GNA go
Greg you're like a son to me should
sending me these photos why would you
paint our relationship this way and I
think if there's one thing you love more
than receiving gifts is giving gifts and
you will give me the gift a less
in behavior of knowing when I'm crossing
the line hey and you got to cross the
line to find it based off of the
scrutinization you dish my way for being
um a callous with my behavior yes
keeping you honest so I appreciate you
Maria always keeping me in check my
sweet sweet hot mom
you greggy's mom has got it going on
this Christmas yeah
and I'm gonna get you a ham oh and I'll
get you some
almonds and then you can crust the ham
it can be ham Hamond where' you get the
Almond from uh I thought the first half
of Hammond is ham and the second half is
Mund and the second half of almond is
also Mund so I was like I'm getting her
a Polaroid of me naked and you're
getting her an almond you said you're
getting her a ham I can I can I'll paint
a self portra myself and to her in
addition to the AL sorry about the let
down there Mar okay no it's up to you to
decide it okay we love you dear Merry
Christmas I hope you have a good one
with your family this year you deserve
it you
[Music]
do